United’s flight 3411 was scheduled to leave
Chicago O’hare airport at 5:40 pm on Sunday,
April 9th to Louisville, Kentucky, but after
dragging a passenger off the flight and a
two hour delay, it turned into one of the
biggest PR disasters an airline has ever seen.
Of course, the impetus of this entire news
story is that airlines sell more seats than
they have—its just better business.
With any flight, a certain number of people
won’t show up—that’s called the no-show
rate.
Flying with an empty seat is a lost opportunity
for an airline to make money—even if someone
did buy a ticket for that seat—so many airlines
have instilled complicated systems to predict
how many people will miss their flight.
That no-show rate varies hugely by route and
date.
In United’s network, Chicago, where flight
3411 left from, likely has a high no-show
rate since it is their hub.
A large percentage of the passengers taking
a flight from Chicago connect from another
flight and, since 1/4 of US domestic flights
arrive late, many people miss connections.
In addition, there are a ton of competing
airlines and modes of transportation from
Chicago so it’s not a huge deal for passengers
to change their plans to leave a few hours
or days later.
On a flight from, say, Bangor, Maine, a small
rural airport, to Washington DC, passengers
are much less likely to miss or decide not
to show up for their flight.
No passengers are connecting through Bangor
onto this flight to DC and there are also
very few alternatives.
With only 10-15 flights a day and no train
service, missing a flight out of Bangor is
much more inconvenient than one out of Chicago.
Flights on Sunday nights, like flight 3411,
are also likely to have a lower no-show rate
since travellers are wary to get back to work
on Monday.
There’s no good public data on how many
passengers miss their flights—it’s a closely
guarded secret—but this data is used by
airlines to build models that predict how
many seats they can safely oversell.
The good news is that these models are getting
better.
In 1990 US airlines denied boarding to about
16 out of every 10,000 passengers while today
its down to 9 out of every 10,000 passengers.
With better and better data and smarter and
smarter programs, these models are constantly
improving to let airlines sell these nonexistent
seats more safely.
In the end, what airlines pay to compensate
those half a million yearly passengers who
are bumped from their flights is far less
than the hundreds of millions of dollars they
can make overbooking—until of course, it
turns into a worldwide PR disaster.
So how can you be sure that you won’t be
bumped?
When airlines do have to involuntarily select
individuals to offload, they’ll often use
a hierarchical system—choosing the individuals
that supposedly have the least merit to be
on the flight or least value to the airline
on paper.
Normally a computer will pick those who checked
in last and have no or low frequent flier
status.
So, if you check in early, even online, select
a seat, and get your boarding pass, you’re
much more likely to fly on your flight.
In addition, having a frequent flier account,
even if you don’t use it much, will improve
your odds over the majority of people who
don’t have one at all.
You can also fly airlines that overbook less:
JetBlue had to involuntarily deny boarding
to only 18 out of its 21 million passengers
in 2013.
Since they sell mostly sell inflexible tickets
with fewer connections, passengers are much
more likely to show up for their flight so
JetBlue has a blanket policy not to overbook
flights.
What you have to remember with airlines, however,
is that they’re constantly trying to find
ways to make more money per seat so that they
can reduce ticket prices.
That’s not to say they’re altruistic organizations,
they just recognize that the number one determinant
to whether someone will fly their airline
is that one number—the ticket price—so
they’ll take almost any opportunity to reduce
it in order to gain a competitive advantage.
Time and time again it’s been proven that
the majority of consumers want cheaper flights
more than they want a better travel experience—that’s
why budget airlines are making such a disruption—so
this whole trend of unbundled airfares, fees
for everything, and even overbooking is all
in response to what the consumer as one entity
wants—cheap flights.
I hope you enjoyed this short and extra Wendover
Productions video.
If you’d like to support the channel, you
can do so over at patreon.com/WendoverProductions.
I’d also encourage you to subscribe to catch
all my future videos right when they come
out and follow me on Twitter @WendoverPro
to get updates along the way.
Lastly, if you enjoyed this video you’d
probably enjoy the one on the Economics of
Airlines Class which you can find here.
Thanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
two weeks for the next full-length Wendover
Productions video.